allora l'argomento della mia
conversazione è lo spopolamento in
sardegna
credo però che sia opportuno premettere
tre considerazioni di carattere generale
anche per meglio inquadrare il caso
sardegna
la prima considerazione che tra i
fenomeni economici quindi tra la
crescita economica e i fenomeni
demografici c'è un rapporto molto forte
proprio recentemente un libro molto noto
ha ribadito il fatto che l'aumento la
crescita quella che normalmente viene
chiamata la crescita cioè l'aumento del
pil è fortemente legato alle dinamiche
demografiche per cui in passato abbiamo
avuto una grande crescita del pil anche
collegata a una grande crescita
demografica e che significa che quando
la popolazione diminuisce molto
difficilmente si può avere un fenomeno
di crescita del pil
la seconda considerazione riguarda più
in generale il fatto che i fenomeni
demografici più di qualunque altro
fenomeno sociale hanno una fortissima
inerzia
il che significa le grandezze che
normalmente fanno parte della demografia
e natalità mortalità nuzialità eccetera
eccetera
cambiano molto lentamente nel tempo il
che significa anche se nel caso della
cina e politica è anche molto
determinate molto autoritarie per
esempio per ridurre o per aumentare la
natalità impiegano decenni per poter
avere degli effetti sensibili non basta
cioè della in altri termini una
qualunque legge o provvidenza
governativa per determinare
automaticamente un aumento ad esempio
della natalità la terza considerazione è
che oggi siamo in presenza di un della
fine di quella che era stata una
preoccupazione che dura da decenni
diciamo così accesa da un libro
famosissimo nel 72 del gruppo del pd e
del club di roma improvvisamente
tradotto in italiano i limiti dello
sviluppo
che spaventava riprendendo tra l'altro
una lunga tradizione delle scienze
sociali una crescita spaventosa della
popolazione la cosiddetta bomba
demografica che avrebbe portato
all'esaurimento diciamo così delle
risorse della terra nell'arco di pochi
decenni
questa previsione si è risultata
completamente sballata dell'inizio groth
prevedeva che nel 2020 avremmo avuto 20
miliardi gli abitanti sulla terra
in realtà siamo vicini ai 7 poco
superiore ai 7 miliardi cioè diciamo che
la dinamica sia invertita quindi una
previsione che non è stata corretta
non solo ma nella gran parte del mondo
cosiddetto sviluppato oggi abbiamo un
problema che non è di sovrapopolazione
ma casomai di sotto popolazione cioè nel
senso che c'è un declino demografico
marcatissimo una serie di conseguenze
che troverò brevemente anche altro cane
in europa per esempio si fa fronte a un
declino demografico che crea numerosi
problemi
si pensi che le previsioni fanno
prevedere che l'europa la popolazione
dell'europa circa 500 milioni nel 2050
dovrebbe essere diminuita di dieci per
cento di 10 milioni rispetto alla
situazione attuale
questo nonostante un saldo positivo di
40 milioni di immigrati
il che vuol dire che nonostante gli
immigrati si fanno talmente pochi figli
in europa ha detto in maniera molto
brutale banale che il declino della
popolazione europea soprattutto quella
di origine europea è destinato
fatalmente a diminuire si pensi che in
demografia si usa il tasso di fecondità
e si dice che quando il tasso di
fecondità è inferiore a 2,1 tasso di
fecondità vuol dire il numero di figli
che ogni donna fa la sua vita feconda
la popolazione entra in sofferenza la
struttura demografica si distorce beh in
europa
nessun paese raggiunge 2,1
i paesi che hanno già da anni avviato
una politica di sviluppo della natalità
come la francia come regno unito come la
finlandia e paesi scandinavi sono vicini
all 1,9 quindi comunque sotto a quel
livello che consente la riproduzione
della popolazione in fase stazionaria in
italia siamo all 1,45
quindi ancora più sotto in sardegna
siamo all 1,15
quindi ancora più sotto qui c'è un
problema di popolazione della sardegna
che è secondo le previsioni da qui al
diminuisce del 10 per cento e da qui al
2060 diminuisce del 17 per cento
questo significa che esiste un problema
della sardegna nel suo complesso
intesa complessivamente di popolazione
ma la sardegna si complica perché
all'interno della sardegna c'è un
fenomeno molto importante che va avanti
da decenni di modifica radicale degli
assetti degli stanziamenti della
popolazione nel senso che dopo una
tendenza perlomeno millenaria non è
sempre stato così nella storia ma
perlomeno da duemila anni le popolazioni
rifuggono le coste e vivevano
soprattutto all'interno per tante
ragioni la malaria quasi tutte le coste
erano malariche le invasioni eccetera
eccetera
la stessa forma di economia prevalente
che prevedeva l'allevamento brado e
quindi le zone interne della roma
finalmente vocate per questa per questo
utilizzo negli ultimi 50 anni si è dato
un fenomeno e si assolutamente si può
definire la ciambella il centro della
sardegna si è progressivamente votarlo
si sono riempite le coste è possibile
individuare un diagonale che va grosso
modo dal nord ovest al sud est della
sardegna
in cui la maggior parte dei comuni
se non tutti sono in uno stato di grave
gravissima sofferenza demografica e che
vuol dire che perdono popolazione il che
vuol dire che i morti sono superiori ai
lati il che vuol dire che c'è
evidentemente un invecchiamento molto
pesante della popolazione che nel
complesso su 377 comuni della sardegna
260 circa sono in stato di sofferenza
demografica gravi o gravissime si può
anche facilmente prevedere che se le
tendenze sono quelle degli ultimi 20
anni
da qui al 2035 2050
interi paesi spariscono non ci sono più
in desertifica territorio
ora perché lo spopolamento è un problema
grave e proviamo anche a dire qualcosa
sui due aspetti
poi su cui si svilupperà il ragionamento
cioè le cause dello spopolamento e i
possibili rimedi
cioè cosa si può fare se si può fare
qualcosa allora lo spopolamento e un
fenomeno del tipo circolo vizioso
c'è un fenomeno che si autoalimenta più
un comune perde popolazione più un
territorio perde popolazione più è
destinato a perdere altra perché meno
popolazione significa meno domanda di
servizi e di conseguenza meno servizi e
di conseguenza si moltiplicano si
replicano le condizioni che rendono
stimolante andasse attrattivo la
prospettiva di andarsene è un fenomeno
molto grave perché è un fenomeno molto
grave perché in primo luogo ma questo ce
lo insegnano i geologi gli urbanisti una
quantità di discipline ce lo insegnano
quando la montagna o la collina medio
alta lo avevano una gran di montagna ma
la collina medio alta si spopola soffre
la pianura dal punto di vista geologico
perché viene meno quella manutenzione
del territorio dell'ambiente che nei
secoli ha in qualche modo garantito
che fenomeni metereologici che peraltro
diventano sempre meno improbabili anzi
diventano sempre più probabili fuori
controllo possano creare quelle plastico
i guai che peraltro in sardegna negli
ultimi anni abbiamo in varie situazioni
conosciuto la seconda ragione è che la
sardegna nella sua storia nella sua
identità è una terra di comuni di paesi
cioè se spariscono i paesi sparisce
anche una pezzo dell'identità della
sardegna è una parte della storia della
sardegna anche delle rivalità tra i
paesi fa parte della storia della
sardegna per cui questi paesi hanno una
importanza cioè la storia il passato e
ieri non stiamo parlando di un passato
remotissimo a ieri e l'altro ieri terzo
ed ultimo non per importanza il fatto
che quando la popolazione non c'è o è
molto anziana si prevede per esempio
sempre le previsione del 2050 che nel
2000 adesso siamo al 20 per cento di
popolazione con più di 65 anni nel 2050
nel complesso della sardegna siamo al 30
per cento di popolazione con più di 65
anni
ovviamente nelle zone spopolate la
percentuale è ancora più alta
allora non è banale fare la domanda come
si può immaginare un processo di
sviluppo con popolazione over 65
come si può immaginare un processo di
sviluppo significa impiegare risorse per
il futuro creare le basi per il futuro
come si può immaginare che le persone
che hanno superato una certa soglia di
età possono avere questo grande futuro
lo dico con dispiacere perché ovviamente
anche io sono di quelli che non hanno un
grande futuro ma evidentemente è un
problema molto serio
non servono i piani di sviluppo se non
c'è popolazione questo voglio dire in
sostanza e quindi da questo punto di
vista lo spopolamento è una una
variabile decisiva per immaginare le
possibili soluzioni
perché i comuni si spopolano c'è una
letteratura ormai sterminata non del
tutto convincente però perché alla fine
si tirano fuori sempre le solite cose in
realtà non spiegano una causa
sicuramente la mancanza di occupazione
il che porta a dire che più che altro è
la percezione che altrove ci sia
occupazione che porta allo spopolamento
non è il fatto che altrove ce ne sia
effettivamente di più il dramma della
disoccupazione oggi è un problema serio
in tutte le aree sviluppate ma
soprattutto nelle aree urbane
qualcuno potrà essere stupito ma ci sono
c'è un tasso di disoccupazione più alto
a cagliari che non ha ruolo per il
semplice motivo che dove c'è più
popolazione che cerca cerca lavoro
direttamente i tassi ne risentono
l'altra seconda ragione sono i servizi
dalla sanità l'istruzione a internet è
un grosso problema per buona parte delle
zone interne della sardegna ancora ma si
è visto che anche sulla base di
esperienze di altri paesi
e quando si fanno grandi investimenti in
infrastrutture in servizi la tendenza
il trend non cambia il posto
spopolamento continua d'altra parte noi
abbiamo la prova in sardegna nella zona
del morese soprattutto c'è una
concentrazione di sale congressi centri
congressi impianti sportivi palestre
comunali cosa del genere costruite negli
anni 70 e 80
forse per cercare di arginare lo
spopolamento che però sono dalla miglior
pan della maggior parte dei casi
inutilizzate e ormai spesso
inutilizzabili perché sapete bene
una struttura che la quale non si fa
manutenzione dopo poco diventa
inutilizzabile
quindi non si può dire che sia soltanto
la mancanza di servizi anche se
certamente le difficoltà dei servizi
rappresentano un elemento che incide
sullo spopolamento
la ragione che a mio avviso complessa
più sfumata ma anche sintetizza tutte le
altre è il fatto che nella nostra
società nella cosiddetta società moderna
si è affermato un modo una cultura un
ideale di vita che è quello della città
quello del modello urbano industriale
quindi della città con tutto ciò che la
città significa prima di tutto la città
rappresenta sociologicamente
antropologicamente la liberazione da
tutta una serie di condizionamenti che
derivano dal controllo sociale che è
molto forte nelle piccole comunità
lo dico con una battuta una ragazza che
incontrò un ragazzo in un piccolo paese
dell'interno dopo tre ore è
ufficialmente fidanzata
la ragazza non ama una cosa del genere
forse neanche il ragazzo e quando
possono se ne vanno dove in città la
città è anonima tutti puoi incontrare
nessuno ti vede nessuno ti conosce offre
dei vantaggi la città è il luogo degli
spettacoli qualche volta è fittizia
questa cosa non è importante quanto sia
vera quanto sia creduta vera e quindi la
città attrae attira è un modello di vita
che è assolutamente dominante altrove in
altre parti d'italia e d'europa problema
non è stato risolto definitivamente
ma è stato perlomeno fortemente mitigato
urbanizzando la città
penso alla toscana benz all'umbria penso
all'emilia penso al veneto le campagne
hanno più o meno le stesse strutture gli
stessi servizi che hanno le città per
cui la spinta ad andarsene è una spinta
che è venuta stata attenuata meno forte
nelle campagne e le campagne ci sono
tutte le infrastrutture tutte le
comodità qualche volta addirittura di
più meglio e quelle che sono disponibili
nelle città e questo ha attenuato il
flusso di spopolamento in sardegna
purtroppo le cose non stanno in questi
termini
la campagna non è stata assolutamente
urbanizzata e quindi continua a esserci
questa forte spinta ad andar via ad
andarsene fino a un certo punto c'è una
voglia di tornare ma quanto durerà
questa voglia di tornare
oggi si torna una volta l'anno per la
sagra la festa del patrono per la festa
delle castagne per la festa del delle
fragole di qualunque altra occasione del
genere ma in futuro probabilmente questa
spinta a ritornare verrà sempre meno
quindi è un problema estremamente
complicato come fare cosa fare
è una domanda difficilissima risposta
perché sono necessarie delle politiche
non una sola cosa ma sono necessarie
tante costante politicante cose da fare
assieme probabilmente una chiave di
lettura interessante è quella di
guardare con occhi nuovi e diversi
all'immigrazione
so bene che tocco di nervi scoperti
soprattutto in questa temperie storica
parlare di immigrazione di immigrazione
non godono di una grande simpatia in
questa fase storica
anche perché in maniera piuttosto
erronea si confonde immigrazione con
terrorismo sono due fenomeni
completamente diversi anche se qualche
volta possono presentarsi la sardegna
nella sua storia ha avuto tanti
tentativi di ripopolarla perché il
problema della popolazione sardegna è
sempre stato un problema per moltissimo
vento in tutta la sua storia la scarsità
di popolazione non hanno avuto un
grandissimo successo
beh perché non immaginare che così come
i sardi sono andati a occupare i terreni
abbandonati in toscana dai locali altri
possano prendere il posto dei sardi che
hanno abbandonato i terreni nelle zone
interne della sardegna
certo che qui non è un discorso da fare
in maniera superficiale generico dicendo
apriamo agli immigrati
si tratta di fare di metter in atto
delle politiche
naturalmente
c'è qualche segnale nel dibattito
politico
ho sentito recentemente qualcuno che
timidamente tirava fuori questa idea e
credo che bisogna prenderla con molta
pacatezza con molta serenità con molta
calma ma anche con molta intelligenza
senza confondere i fenomeni di breve
periodo
come può essere l'attuale flusso
disordinato che viene da paesi
drammaticamente coinvolti in episodi di
guerra come la siria in iraq lo stesso
afghanistan a guardare a una prospettiva
più ampia e partire da una
considerazione
si può anche immaginare della politica
che si possa avere dei canali
privilegiati immaginaria dei contratti
degli accordi dei rapporti quindi
sostanzialmente guardiamo a questa
prospettiva
tenendo conto che l'immigrazione è un
problema ma potrebbe anche essere una
risorsa non un problema
grazie